congratulations That's how the
bulletin was taught now With what
former
awe and confidence that now finally
what we have been fighting for so long is finally
happening Returning home
Returning to Great Russia
[music]
okay Today we have a solemn
event, so to speak, a
significant day today finally
what is happening is what we have been waiting for a very long,
painful eight years Today we have
a referendum on the first day of absentee
voting on the fact that the Luhansk
People's Republic
entered
the Russian Federation as a subject of the
Russian Federation for a very long time we have been
waiting for this very painfully it
all happened a lot of life for
this
[music]
ready to vote Yes, I was really looking forward to
joining the Russian Federation
due to the fact that due to the recent events in
Ukraine, since the age of 14, it
was no longer possible to simply live there.
started oh it uh  it’s just
the girl’s class is very good just good
it will be super you understand it will be
protection just even the whole of Ukraine became
part of Russia you can’t imagine
it will be a big protection for Ukraine
they will just mock people
[applause]
I am against the referendum because I consider
my small  the town and my region
belong entirely to Ukraine,
this is very difficult
and I think that there is no place for Russians on our land at
all categorically against I think
that the Kherson region is the territory of
Ukraine, this is the second time of
this situation, what is happening there We don’t
know because we are at the
moment  IDPs Since May,
I do not support